Today, we're learning about New Year's dishes.
Japan's most important holiday is the family celebration of the New Year...
...with Osechi or New Year's Dishes.
This time we're making ozoni, one of the most essential dishes for this celebration.
Osechi were originally formal dishes that were offered to the gods...
...for happiness in the New Year.
After these offerings were made,...
...Japanese people enjoyed Osechi dishes with their families.
Ozoni, made with mochi or rice cakes, plays the main role.
Mochi is often toasted and eaten with bonito kombu dashi broth.
Each ingredient in ozoni has a particular meaning for bringing peace in the New Year.